مسلسلات الاردنيه جوليانا صادق تاريخا
جديدا للعرب في رياضه التايكواندو بعدما
تصدرت نجمه المنتخب الاردني تصنيف الدولي
في وزن 67 كلغ كولي لاعبته عربيه تحققوا
هذا الانجاز
الدولي عن شهر يناير كانون الثاني الحالي
حيث اعلنت جوليانا صادق
اعلنت انها في صداره التصنيف العالمي في
وزن 67 كيلوغرام
في التصنيف الاولمبي في الوزن نفسه اضافه
الى انها تقف في المركز الاول في تصنيف
الاوزان العالميه لتكون اول لاعبه عربيه
تحتل المركز الاول عالميه ايضا
من عمان معنا الصادق اللاعب المصنفه
الاولى عالميا في رياضه التايكوندو اول
شيء
الف مبروك
انجاز كبير للغايه
ونحب نسالك عن
ابرز التحديات التي واجهتها لانه ليس من
السهوله بمكان ان تصل الى المرتبه الاولى
في العالم
مساء الخير والله يبارك فيك
يعني هذا الانجاز اجى من وراء التعب كثير
يعني خلال سنين طبعا يعني ما اجا هيك فجاه
همم كنا اكيد همم نتمر كل يوم من خلال
اشهر وسنوات
وانا دائما بحكي بصيغه الجمع لانه اكيد مش
همم مش انا كشخص لحالي قدرت اوصل لهون
اكيد فيك ناس ناعمين لي لحتى قدرت اوصل
هون
يعني التحديات كثير واجهت التحديات همم
خلال مسيره الرياضيه
ومن ابرزها يعني
اصابات
اصابات وتحديات كثير كبيره حتى يعني همم
يعني واجهتني ممكن كانت تخليني اوقف اني
العب بس الحمد لله قدرت اني يعني استمر
وقدرت اني اتاهل الاولمبيكس
باكسوكيو 2020
واكيد يعني بطمح لحتى اني كمان اقدر اتاهل
كمان مره ثانيه واحصل على ميداليه اولمبيه
همم جوليا هي رياضه عنيفه توصلنا وفي
العموم صعبه وليست سهله على الرجال فما
بالك على النساء كيف تعاملتي مع صعوبه هذه
الرياضه وخصوصها
هلا اكيد هي رياضه يعني صعبه اكيد مش سهله
همم بس اكيد انا صغيره بلعب رياضه فمتعوده
على همم يعني انه اكون همم رياضيه محترفه
من انا صغيره عشان والدي ايه هو اصلا همم
مدرب سيكوندو كنت العب همم جمباز قبل ما
اتجاه لعبه التايكوندو
فااا اكيد ال همم التاسيس من الصغار كثير
بساعد همم حتى الواحد يعني يقدر يستمر
يعني انا اليوم عمري 28 والحمد لله انه
يعني قادره استمر لانه الاساس انه قوي
فهذا الشيء كمان لازم يعني همم انا بحب
انه الصبايا همم
والبنات انه
الرياضه من عمر صغير حتى يقدر يوصلوا ولا
مراحل متقدمه يقدروا همم نفسه على منصات
التتويج العالميه
هذه همم الرياضه بالنسبه للاباء والامهات
اللي بيتفرجوا علينا الان ويفكرون ان هم
يشركوا همم اولادهم وبناتهم بشكل خاص في
الرياضات كهذه
ماذا اضافت الى شخصيتك منذ الصغر
الاصراحه انا حبي للتايكوندو خلاص الناس
اللي بتعرفني كثير منيحه بتعرف قديش انا
متعلقه في هذه اللعبه همم اكيد اضافه
لشخصيتي كثير اشياء يعني ثقه بالنفس وتحدي
يعني بتخلي عند الواحد انه تحدي مش بس انه
بلعبه التايكوندو حتى بره اللعبه
التايكوندو انه هو همم يعني اكيد اي شيء
بطناح له خصوصا همم بلعبه التايكوندو او
بره لعبه التايكوندو دائما بحب اني اوصل
له يعني اكون انه اتحدى حالي قبل ما اتحدى
الناس اللي حوالي همم يعني اضافه كثير
لشخصيتين وهمم وكمان طبعا انا بالنسبه لي
يعني مبسوطه بالحياه حياتي اني انا لاعب
احترافيه والناس تستغرب انه همم
بتعملي بحياتك باحكي لهم انا لاعبه محترفه
همم والمجتمع العربي يعني شويه غريبه
عليها هذه الجمله يعني ما بعرف انه يعني
لاعب
محترفين يعني ههه
احنا يمكن نفهم لاعب كره قدم محترف بس
اللاعب التايكوندو محترفه
في الوطن العربي عموما انه الاحتراف في
بالنسبه للنساء توصل لمرحله المرتبه
الاولى كمان التصنيف العالمي هذا هو
الجديد بالنسبه للمنطتنا
اكيد يعني هلا انا بعتبره بالنسبه لالي
يعني التايكوندو هي حياتي
وكمان يعني شغلي يعني زي ما نحكي عشان هيك
بحكي لكم انه لاعب محترفه يعني انا تاركه
كل شيء بحياتي ومخصصيته للتايكوندو هاي هي
انه الاحتراف بمعنى الكلمه يعني كيف
لاعبين القدم ان الناس تعرف انه هم بس
يعني
ههه
لاعب كره القدم
حلو كويس ههه هلا اكيد يعني بلش ال ااه
يعني بلشت الرياضات انه الفرديه تتحسن بس
اكيد مش نفس الرياضات الجماعيه فبتمنى انه
يكون هذا كمان الموضوع يعني يزيد همم من
اقبال الناس على ممارسه الالعاب الفرديه
همم يعني بتمنى انه يزيدوا الدعم همم
بالنسبه للرياضه الفرديه لانه عن جد نحنا
كعرب نقدر ننجز يعني الحمد لله نحن اكيد
همم اخر بطوله لالي شاركت فيها اللي هي
اجرام فري فاير اللي هي بطوله الجائز
الكبرى همم بس ضمن المصلى فين 16 على
العالم
همم وهي اكيد بطوله جدا صعبه الحمد لله
قدرت احق فيها الذهبيه وكانت يعني بصراحه
حلم بالنسبه لي يعني وكثير مبسوطه انه
قدرت انه اتحدى حالي رغم كل شيء اييه وصار
معي الفتره الاخيره وان قدرت تحقق المدارس
الذهبيه فاكيد يعني
اكيد بتمنى انه يكون في دعم كمان اكثر
للرياضات
التي تعكس بالفعل همم هويه الفتاه العربيه
همم برايك هل الفتاه العربيه قادره على ان
تحرز ارقاما تتجاوز همم مشاركات او فوز
فردي الى نتحدث عن اسماء كثيره على مستوى
الوطن العربي في رياضات مختلفه من ضمن
التايكوندو
طبعا هلا الحجاب صراحه هو مش مانع ولا
يعني ولا بمنع اي حدا انه يمارس من رياضه
احترافيه ويجيب ميداليات والتوج على يعني
على المنصات التتويج العالميه يعني اكيد
هذا شيء ما باثر بالمره بالعكس انا بكون
فخوره في حاله اني بمثل
يعني الدول العربيه وبيمثل الاسلام بالاخص
يعني باحسن صوره الحمد لله همم كمان بتمنى
انه يعني يشوفون البنات لهم بالعكس عم
بشوف هذا الحكي كثير مبسوطه من البنات
اللي عم تقبلوا للتايكوندو وكمان محجبين
يعني فهل شيء كثير حلو
عموما يعني انت بطله وليس من سهل ان يصل
اي شخص الى البطوله يعني بحاجه الى عمل
شاقوب وانضباط كبير فنوجه لك التحيه
ولوالدك ولكل الفريق الذي عمل معك ساعدنا
جدا بوجودك معنا نتمنى لك التوفيق الف
مبروك مره ثانيه شكرا جزيلا لك اذا
جوليانا الصادق اللاعب المصنفات شكرا
الاولى على ميجان في رياضه التايكوندو